- [Voiceover] We're now
ready to start the study
of circuit analysis and to design circuits
and analyze circuits, one
of the things we need to do
is have something to build circuits with
and that's what we're gonna
talk about in this video.
The idea is we're gonna
have three circuit elements.
These circuit elements
are called resistor,
capacitor,
i-tor,
and inductor.
Okay, these are the three passive
or two-element components
or circuit elements that
we're gonna use to design
a lot of different kinds of circuits.
First, I want to introduce a
symbol for each one of these
so we can talk about it
and making drawings of it
and first is gonna be the resistor.
Resistor symbol looks like this.
It's a zigzag line like that
representing current going
through and being resisted
having to do some work.
Another symbol for
resistor looks like this
used in other parts of the world
besides the United States and Japan.
That's what a resistor looks like
and the symbol we use is R.
Now for the capacitor,
capacitor symbol is
actually a capacitor's built
from two conductors or metal objects
that are placed close together
and most capacitors sort of look like that
when they're actually built
and the symbol for capacitor is a C.
And finally for the inductor,
we'll do inductors like this.
An inductor is actually
built from a coil of wire
and so when we draw an inductor symbol,
we draw a little coil of wire like that
and the symbol is L which is a little odd.
It could be called i but the symbol for i
was already taken by current
which is from the French for intensity
and we couldn't use C for current
because the C is used here
so it's a little quirk
of our nomenclature.
All right.
Each of these components has an equation
that goes along with it
that relates the voltage to the current.
Now, I'm gonna go back here.
I'm gonna label the voltages
and currents on here
in a very important convention
for drawing circuits.
Let's do that.
When we talk about the
voltage on a component,
we can label it however
we want, plus-minus V,
and we draw the current going in.
I'll just label a little i there
and we'll do it on all these.
The current goes into
the positive terminal.
the positive terminal
so that's a V on the capacitor
and finally,
and the current goes in
and we're gonna be very
consistent about this
and that's gonna keep
us from making mistakes.
All right, so let's go
back to our resistor
and we're gonna do the
equation for a resistor.
What is the I-V equation for a resistor?
I-V equation means what
relates current to voltage
and for a resistor, it's V
equals i times R
so the voltage across the resistor
is equal to the current
through the resistor
times this constant of proportionality
that we call the resistance.
This has a very important name.
This is called Ohm's law
and you're gonna use this a lot
so that's Ohm's law right there.
This is Ohm's law.
Now for the IV relationship
for the capacitor,
the capacitor has that
property that the current
through the capacitor is
proportional to the rate of change
of the voltage, not to the
voltage but to the rate of change
of the voltage and the way we
write that is current equals,
C is the proportionality constant,
and we write dv, dt
so this is the rate of change of voltage
with respect to time.
We multiply that by this
property of this device
called capacitance and
that gives us the current.
This doesn't have a special name
but I'm gonna refer to it
as the capacitor equation
so now we have two equations.
Let's do the third equation
which is for the inductor.
The inductor has the property
very similar to the capacitor.
It has the property
that the voltage across
is proportional to the time
rate of change of the current
flowing through the inductor
so this is a similar but opposite
of how a capacitor works.
The voltage is proportional
to the time rate of change
of current and the way we write that
is voltage equals L,
di, dt.
The voltage is proportional.
The proportionality
constant is the inductants.
The inductance of the inductor
and this is the time rate
of change of voltage,
OH sorry, the time rate
of change of current
flowing through the inductor
so this gives us our three equations.
Here they are.
These are three element equations
and we're gonna use these all the time,
right there, those three equations.
One final point I wanna make
is for both these equations of components,
these are ideal, ideal components.
That means these things are
mathematical perfect things
that we have in our minds
that we're gonna try to build
in the real world but we'll come close.
We'll come very close.
We now have a wonderful set of equations:
V equals iR,
i equals C, dv, dt.
v equals L, di, dt.
These are gonna be like
poetry for you pretty soon
and these ideal equations will produce
all kinds of really cool circuits for us.